l'avenir des quelques 250 mille
travailleurs immigrés s'assombrit au
liban en cause la crise du coc vide qui
touche durement le pays et la double
explosion qui a touché le port de
beyrouth et coûté la vie à plus de 180
personnes dont au moins douze
travailleurs étrangers
la situation de ces derniers s'aggrave
de jour en jour sans emploi parfois à la
rue après avoir vu leur contrat de
travail
annuler ou la maison de leurs patrons
détruite par l'explosion des femmes
quand devant le consulat de leur pays
afin de demander de l'aide et leur
rapatriement dans leur pays d'origine
quand mon contrat au liban s'est achevée
je voulais rentrer en gambie mais ils
ont refusé de me laisser partir
j'ai donc abandonné mon contrat et me
suis enfui et j'ai continué à travailler
je me suis mariée ici et j'ai un enfant
vous savez c'est très dur
et en plus de tout ça il y a eu
l'explosion et l'économie est en crise
l'équivalent de 100 dollars c'est à
présent sept cent mille ou même un
million de livres libanaises qui peut se
permettre une telle somme pour acheter
un billet pour rentrer dans son pays
homeplug n'a je suis enceinte et je suis
dans la rue parce que je veux rentrer
chez moi en ce moment je n'ai pas
d'endroit où dormir seulement la rue et
mon but est de rentrer chez moi
la famille pour laquelle je travaillais
m'a renvoyé à lagence --l'agence n'a
cessé de me changer de maison et je n'ai
pas reçu ou salaire depuis six mois
souvent originaires d'afrique ces
travailleurs viennent au liban dans
l'espoir de gagner suffisamment d'argent
pour soutenir leur famille dans leur
pays d'origine
mais le système de parrainage appelé
kafala est controversé car il prive les
travailleurs de certains droits et
permet aux employeurs de leurs confisqué
leurs passeports à leur arrivée sur le
territoire
une situation qualifiée d' esclavage
moderne par certaines ong
cela fait maintenant une semaine que je
suis dans la rue pour aider des femmes
kenyanes de badaro a interpellé leur
consulat
elles sont en fait ici depuis deux
semaines mais nous n'en étions pas
informé avant les problèmes qu'elles
rencontrent au liban sont causées par le
système appelé cafal qui est un
esclavage des temps modernes elle
travaille sans salaire elles sont
surchargés travail parfois elles sont
mal traités et au bout du compte elles
ont été jetés à la rue par leurs
employeurs et font maintenant face au
consulat de leur pays dans un pays
empêtré dans une grave crise financière
depuis plusieurs mois l'avenir de ces
travailleurs immigrés sur le sol
libanais s'inscrit chaque jour un peu
plus entre parenthèses